Rachel's with us in Sioux Falls hi
Rachel and welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show thank you thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well my husband was
caught up in an online illicit affair
with a woman overseas who scammed him
out of over $150,000 and with the
promise of course to pay it back and
this was over time from last July until
recently when I discovered it all and he
has taken a number of loans out pretty
much $135,000 of loans some of which are
from some friends but mostly through a
bank on secured loans through bank
rather online lending and I you know
double-edge here's number one the affair
but I'm here to talk about the financial
devastation yeah so the the affair was
emotional online he never physically
visited her right of course there was
the promise she was coming supposedly
American coming to the u.s. to come back
home but right all of that but I'm just
saying the nature of the affair yes
emotional yeah deeply rooted in motion
over here yeah and all kinds of other
stuff that we don't even want to know
about okay all right and we've been
married 33 years all right so you're
seeing a marriage counselor yes both of
you yes and your intention is to work
through this I believe so I mean I this
is more for the marriage counselor at
rebuilding trust is going to be massive
but yeah really it's it's a financial
devastation because included with an in
addition to those loans Dave he also
emptied out the IRA we had and another
investment we had plus took 5,000 in
cash out of our joint account over time
it's it's massive financial devastation
read me this 200 left in our savings
account that's it yeah
and what is his income and income is
about eighty one thousand what is your
income not a whole lot maybe ten
thousand a year I've been a full-time
homemaker home school seven kids adopted
kids so made kids you know are they all
grown going we have one special needs
son who's not he's in a residential
right now but other than that it's an
empty nest he does oh so you're 55 maybe
pardon me
how old are you 55 I'm 58 he's 68 okay
well if you I suspect you have a really
good counselor I hope you do because his
behavior is so dark and it's it has
taken him to such a place of stupidity
that the trust it's more than a simple
affair emotional or physical that's a
one-off it's more than simply him lying
about some money things this is an
ongoing process that has taken two
extremes on both of these fronts and so
this is very very dark and so for you to
rebuild trust is more than massive it's
it's a big deal
any sixty eight years old Wow okay
yeah you're gonna have to have you're
gonna have to come have complete control
of the finances and then gradually
involve him after that he has zero
rights to any money if you stay zero he
does not have access to it in any way
we're going to treat him like he's a
cocaine addict and can't help himself
because apparently that's about where
his brain is mm-hmm so if you call me up
and said my husband's been doing cocaine
for three years and lost 200 grand and
we're completely broke this is the same
thing I would tell you because that's
what this sounds like because it's so
deep so dark and so layered over such an
extreme period of time now again I'm not
a counselor in the financial world so I
are in the marriage world or the
behavior world so I hope you have a good
one and I hope he has a good one but
that's what I'm observing because I've
worked with people in so many bizarre
behavior breakdowns over the years so I
would treat this that way I would say
you have 100% control of all money and
all assets and after a year we'll talk
about letting him have a little bit of
say in it after two years we'll talk
about putting starting to put his name
back on a couple of things he will never
again have solo access to anything yeah
he's lost that right I mean because 10
years from now he'll be 78 and it 10
years from now you're still going to be
couching from this and to some degree
emotionally and to some degree
financially so that's the road you've
got to take and actually if you guys
emotionally and maritally can't stay
together that is your best bet for
recovery financially because otherwise
you're a lady trying to live off of
alimony making 10 grand yeah well I
would have to go yeah you don't think
you'd have to have a career again and
and you'd have a nice alimony check out
of that and all of this debt would be
his problem so actually you might come
out better financially that way but I
don't ever recommend people divorce that
don't want the divorce and I because I
believe in marriage and I know you do
and you're trying to fight to save this
and I want to fight
to save it so yeah the only way you stay
in this is a febrile ink which is all
control now let me ask you this the bank
or the online lenders program those have
started coming due he borrowed them in
October and December and January thirty
five thousand twenty thousand and twenty
two thousand and they do auto draft out
of your sugar or shut down your checking
account move your checking account so
this is this is one of the things that's
been talking to him about I you know
that is our money
stop it stop it don't give them any
money right now until you decide how you
want to work with them them having full
access to your checking account has got
to stop because you can't control you
can't control the situation and if you
don't pay them eventually they will sue
you and if you don't pay them eventually
you'll work out a payment plan with them
but it will never again include full
access to your checking account this is
going to get adversarial did you simply
don't have this kind of money with his
income I mean if he made a hundred and
eighty we could talk about trying to
plow through this in a year you know but
this is gonna take two or three years to
clean up and the only way it's going to
clean up is if they don't control the
dialogue and they don't control the
financials the math on this so I tell
you what Theresa do this hold on I'm
gonna have Kelly pick up I'm gonna put
you with one of our financial coaches oh
it's not Theresa it's Rachel I'm sorry
I'm gonna put you with one of our
financial coaches as my gift no charge
to you guys to walk you guys walk with
you guys if your marriage stays together
we want to help you be part of that and
if it doesn't or we want to help you